what does it feel like when you're the
action star of the year what is it what
is that what is that like it was like a
lot of pressure to get to the gym yeah I
don't love working out I have to tell
you it's like not my favorite thing I
really enjoy sitting on a couch but now
that you become action star of the Year
means it probably means you have to work
out year-round not just when you're
doing a movie so it feels like a lot of
pressure man it feels like an albatross
on my back to be honest not no more no
of course it's like amazing and I I
never thought I'd be in that company
like I always thought my career I'd be a
villain really yeah I know I'm the guy
like chasing the villain so it's a weird
turn yeah you're also on a roll you you
we're gonna talk about how abou but you
also have black widow strangers three
tell me about real quick about Black
Widow what can you tell us anything or
do they kill you they kill you in Marvel
if you could divulge anything kick me
out so fast you know look here's what I
will say it's being directed by this
woman Kate Shortland who is a phenomenal
director she directed a movie called
lore she's a phenomenal director so
what's really exciting to me about it is
that it's gonna be like a real deep
interesting film and so yeah I'm just
excited for it as a film as well as the
super moon your co-star may come in
shape I'm saying she may come and arrive
in shape yeah she'll be in far better
shape than me but that's fine all right
who was the Hellboy makeup like what was
that whole deal way it was
like torture yeah it was like three
hours of no it wasn't that bad it was I
actually kind of got into it as it went
on like I spent so much time and it was
three hours in the day in the first
couple weeks you're just miserable and
then I started to fall in love with
Hellboy's face and like identify with it
much more than my own face and so I kind
of like got really into it like I'd get
in the chair get kind of excited you
know that's a way when you come out of
the makeup you'd look at yourself like
not down with that guy yeah I'd pass
myself in law and in like the bathroom
of my hotel room and I'd be freaked out
and then I put on the Hellboy makeup and
I'd be like there is there's a hat to me
that's me yeah I love that I love that
and then stranger things what one you
can't tell us anything about that either
can you can't tell us anything I get
there I mean the trailer came out so I
could tell you that like hoppers got a
whole new look he's got a mustache he's
got a nice you know floral 80's shirt
and you know it's a it's a summer season
and in some ways it's um I'll play this
in some ways it's like the Summer of
Love and Hawkins and very some forms the
Summer of Love
yeah and it's also got monsters and all
kinds of stuff too but in in in a lot of
different ways I would characterize it
as the Summer of Love season
[Music]